[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my video all about why Steve
Jobs is the reason why Disney owns
Marvel we wouldn't have gotten Marvel
phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 avengers endgame
now Marvel phase 4 without Steve Jobs
it's a fascinating story so I'll break
it down we're doing an Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best Marvel
phase 4 Theory on the video when I
announced I was doing a video about
Steve Jobs Apple in Disney a lot of you
were asking about the potential Sony
Apple deal I will address that during
this video I know there are a lot of
questions about what's going on with
Sony because of the Marvel's spider-man
deal don't worry it'll all make sense
but starting with number 10 this story
goes back to 2006 there are four key
people Bob Iger who was CEO of Disney
Steve Jobs Ike Perlmutter who was CEO of
Marvel at the time right now he's just
chairman of the board in Michael Eisner
former CEO of Disney before Bob Iger so
this story about Steve Jobs being the
savior of Marvel and Disney goes back to
2006 it's part of a larger article where
Bob Iger is remembering him close to the
anniversary of his death they became
good friends so Bob Iger was just
talking about his history with Steve
Jobs going back to the mid 2000s also
recently Bob Iger just left Apple's
Board of Directors because Apple and
Disney had a pretty close relationship
because of Steve Jobs because of the
streaming Wars now Apple has their own
streaming service that's directly
competing with Disney Plus so
technically Bob Iger can't be on their
board of directors anymore but going
back in time nine Bob Iger says that
when he first replaced Michael Eisner
CEO of Disney one of the first big
things that he had to do was repair
Disney's relationship with Apple because
at the time Steve Jobs hated Disney
didn't want have anything to do with
them they had previously signed a
licensing deal for Disney to release all
the Pixar films that went back to the
90s things got really contentious
between Steve Jobs and Michael Eisner
when they tried to renegotiate the
contract and famously I think it was
2004 Steve Jobs said that he would never
work at any of his companies with Disney
again not Apple not Pixar no where it
was this big Proclamation he's
permanently shutting Disney out so Bob
Iger did a whole
legwork early on trying to get Steve
Jobs to warm back up to Disney little
while later number eight Bob Iger pushes
Disney to officially by Pixar outright
for over seven billion dollars which
would make Steve Jobs the largest
shareholder at Disney and a lot of
people on the Disney board didn't want
that to happen because they felt like
Steve Jobs would just come in and bully
the Disney CEO to do whatever he wanted
him to do because he's the largest
shareholder so of course financially he
owns a lot of weight but in the tech
world he had had a reputation for being
a bit of a bully in corporate boardrooms
like that so 7 right before both
companies eventually come to terms and
they're getting ready to publicly
announce this multi-billion dollar deal
Steve Jobs privately reveals to Bob Iger
that his cancer has returned and he
would be undergoing treatment but he had
vowed to make it four more years to see
his son's high school graduation and he
did live up to that promise to his son
because he survived another five years
passing away in 2011 this was all
happening back in 2006 but after that
moment Bob Iger and Steve Jobs developed
a really close working relationship and
friendship wherein Steve Jobs was close
enough to criticize his business
decisions as CEO in Bob Iger would take
his counsel to heart like two old Jedi
Masters arguing about the finer points
of business six three years later in
2009 Bob Iger pushes Disney to now buy
marvel because of the success of their
deal in buying out Pixar it made them
tons of money they made their money back
on Pixar on Star Wars on Marvel within a
couple years they were great investments
but at the time people didn't believe
that right away wait you want to spend 7
billion dollars on Pixar is that gonna
be worth it turns out it was totally
worth it so in 2009 they want to do it
again with Marvel not just to get all
the Marvel movies that they'd be making
but for all the merchandise in the
publishing stuff that Marvel does to the
toys the books everything Marvel makes
way more money on toys than it does on
comic books Steve Jobs wasn't totally
convinced of the potential for the deal
5 this is actually kind of funny
Steve Jobs thought of Marvel is a comic
book company first everything else
second he wasn't thinking about Marvel
Entertainment the movies or any of the
other stuff that they would do just
Marvel comics but just a couple years
ago that's usually what you think of
when you say the name Marvel
you think of Marvel Comics Steve Jobs
confessed to never having read a single
comic book in his life he said that he
hated comic books more than he hated
videogames personally I did not know
that Steve Jobs hated videogames but
given apples history in gaming that
totally makes sense so of course Steve
Jobs not superhot on the Marvel deal but
for the way Bob Iger sold Steve Jobs on
the idea was by telling him that he felt
like Marvel would be their next Pixar
and Steve Jobs just trusted his judgment
the problem at this stage was the
current Marvel CEO Ike Perlmutter who
was making all kinds of cash hand over
fist on the merchandising side of things
if you don't know about his history in
the company and how he came to be the
Marvel CEO it's actually pretty
fascinating he wound up owning Marvel
because he in a v-rod owned a toy
company called toy biz remember they
make way more money on the toys than
they do on the comics or the movies so
when Marvel went bankrupt in the 90s
they were already on Marvel's board of
directors they arranged for toy biz
their company to buy out Marvel
instantly making him CEO and giving a V
Arad to control over all the movies
stuff that they were trying to do they'd
already given away most of the rights to
their biggest characters like x-men to
Fox and spider-man to Sony as a way to
get out of bankruptcy but I Perlmutter
wasn't super hot on the idea of being
owned by Disney because he liked having
total control doing whatever he wanted
and he was already making crazy amounts
of cash hand over fist so if he has all
the money in the world then what's gonna
compel him to self to Disney 3 a lot of
you may remember that at this time Kevin
Feige who was president of Marvel
Studios as they were trying to build
that studio out did not have total
control over all the Marvel movies the
CEO other corporate overlords avi arad
could overrule him on which movies they
made story decisions which characters
they included in they often did and it's
really hard to make a good movie when a
bunch of toys salesmen are trying to
tell you what to do in fact before
Marvel Studios was separated from Marvel
Entertainment by Disney in the last
couple of years they were still
negotiating the original deal to get
spider-man in the MCU for Captain
America Civil War during those dealings
Ike Perlmutter almost torpedoed that
deal on several occasions with his
demands
already you kind of sense that if he's
someone that Kevin Feige doesn't want
have anything to do with he's a big
problem and Disney cannot buy Marvel
without him agreeing to it famously or
infamously around the time of Captain
America's Civil War Avengers age of
Ultron Disney separated in Marvel
Studios giving Kevin Feige complete
autonomy from all the other stuff that
Marvel was doing on a corporate level
that did not include Marvel television
so like agents of shield all the network
TV shows when people say that that's
separate from Marvel Studios it's
literally separate now because it's a
completely separate division managed by
completely separate people Kevin Feige
doesn't have any input on the stuff that
they do and they don't have any input on
the stuff that Kevin Feige does that's
why all the movie actors are coming back
for those Avengers spin-off TV shows but
they've never been on the other Marvel
TV shows so back in 2009 - this is where
Steve Jobs swoops in and does his
superhero dance off to save the Marvel
Universe or the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Bob Iger wasn't
making any headway with marbles so Steve
Jobs came in and worked with Marvel to
convince them to sell to Disney which
they did for a little over four billion
dollars seems like chump change compared
to what they paid for Pixar a couple
years earlier but number one because of
all the Spider Man Marvel Disney stuff
that's been going on and now we're
talking about Apple a lot of you have
asked me about the rumor that Apple
might be trying to buy Sony and that
might give Marvel the rights to
spider-man back just to explain how that
works the reason why Marvel would get
the rights to spider-man back if
somebody buys Sony's movie studio the
rights to spider-man do not travel with
them they would revert back to Marvel so
if anybody doesn't matter who buys Sony
Pictures Marvel automatically gets all
those spider-man characters back part of
the reason why I think that people are
talking about this rumor is because
there was an article last year in
variety where they were predicting that
in 2019 Apple would buy Sony for their
IP because Apple's trying to launch
their own streaming service and they
just don't have the content that Disney
has they don't have their own movie
studio but that was just a prediction
that they were making that wasn't based
on any actual evidence and even just
last week the CEO of Sony Pictures said
that they wouldn't be sitting back down
to renegotiate a deal with Disney and
Marvel for the spider-man character for
a hot minute and within the same
interview
you also said that Sony's movie studio
would never be for sale but how crazy is
that story about Steve Jobs being the
savior of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
completely unexpected and all the more
amazing because he hated the idea of
comic books it was all about the
business for him but who cares because
it all worked out in the end I'll be
doing more spider-man videos the next
couple of days some sinister six videos
venom leave all your requests in the
comments below and I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post new Marvel everybody
click here for that brand new Rick and
Morty season 4 trailer and click here
for my new spider-man far from home post
credits scene and Marvel phase 4 teaser
breakdown thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]